of all the Hollywood people I've met you
you have an instant like genuine likable
demeanor whenever I run into you
thank you yeah well that's all the time
we have spot I'm curious know how are
you how's that what you wear but down
from there exactly how are you it's good
I'm doing good I was actually thinking
about you a couple of days ago cuz I I
knew I was going to be on the show and
there's a kind of a la health food
restaurant that I go into like like we
all do whatever I'm in there I get a
smoothie up on the wall there's this
whole collage of like 50 like actors
actresses kind of musicians but it's
pictures of them at this place like
getting their smoothies and getting
their juices and everybody's looking you
know very healthy and pleased with
themselves and I take a big slug of my
smoothie and I'm kind of looking down
the collage squinting at it and I get to
a picture of Conan and everyone everyone
on this thing is smiling or just looking
cool but there's a picture of Conan
holding a smoothie and he's pointing at
it with a horrified expression and so
I'm just taking a big chug of this
smoothie and coughed that up and I'm
looking at all the celebrities thanks we
actually someone went and got a picture
of this I think we have it there
[Laughter]
- buddy whenever I do that on purpose
whenever I'm somewhere and I'm and they
say like hey you know you eating a Big
Mac or something let me get a picture I
always do that so that they can't use
the picture I always go away and then
they don't use the picture this place
didn't this place that used it and
that's that one is at the bottom so I'd
like kind of worked my way all the way
down from like Jessica Alba like Justin
Bieber to Adam Levine and then I get to
Conan with this horrified exercise when
I'd notice just now when they put it up
it looks like down there on the right
Harrison Ford looks like an angry bear
this has been spotted in the woods and
it is about to attack yeah that looked
like kind of a more of a paparazzi show
yeah
you